ich bin jetzt 30 ich bin mutig ich traue
mich heute mal was und deswegen packe
ich stehende Body Shop Adventskalender
aus ja aber Vanessa warum Body Shop ist
doch voll cool ich mag die Body Shop
nicht
nicht so besonders oder mich zieht es da
überhaupt nicht in diesem Laden rein
denn ich finde die Body Shop hat in der
Vergangenheit so wie ich mich erinnere
immer ziemlich schlecht gerochen und ich
konnte nie verstehen warum Menschen dort
Sachen einkaufen das einzige was ich mir
verstanden habe ist das wenn Leute für
ihre Eltern so eine Box geholt haben
weil es war Preis leistungsmäßig ganz
okay aber ich mochte den Duft nie weil
ich euch aber gefragt habe welche
Adventskalender nicht auspacken soll und
wirklich sehr oft genannt wurde machen
wir das
oh
mein Gott oh okay wow das hat so einen
tollen Effekt
ich muss das mal ganz kurz hier auf mich
wirken lassen wow Design top Details top
thank you for been a change Maker
effective assical und wiegen ich will
solche Aussagen eigentlich nicht bei der
kommentieren ich rede hier nicht darüber
wie ökologisch gut diese Produkte sind
aber das designde Partner hat hier
wirklich eine Auszeichnung verdient ich
finde diesen Adventskalender wunderschön
die Pappe fühlt sich gut an das sieht
wunderschön aus hier hast du die Türchen
was und da geht's weiter mit den Türchen
und hier auch noch also der ist schon
sehr sehr schön wenn jetzt noch die
Produkte gut riechen dann haben wir alle
gewonnen und bevor ich jetzt diesen
Kalender noch zu sehr lobe und zu auf
der Body Shop sage dieses Video ist
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alles dieses
Video ist gesponsert
[Musik]
dieses Video ist gesponsert von Holzkern
Holzkern fertig Schmuck und Accessoires
an und ist der führende Hersteller für
Holz Uhren und natürlichen Schmuck in
Europa ich trage super gerne
minimalistischen Schmuck und finde die
besondere Verarbeitung von Holzkern
wirklich wunderschön Holzkern fertig
seine Produkte nämlich aus
Naturmaterialien wie holzstein und
Perlmutt an so dass jedes piece durch
verschiedene Maserungen und
Marmorierungen einzigartig ist ich finde
das Holz kennen sich richtig gut als
Geschenk oder auch als
Weihnachtsgeschenk geeignet als kleine
Symbol zu unserer Verlobung habe ich
Timo einen regen von Holzkern ausgesucht
neben Schmuck und Uhren hat Holzkern
aber auch besondere Accessoires wie z.B
Handtaschen oder Sonnenbrillen mit und
aus Holzelementen womit du immer ein
kleines Stück Natur bei dir trägst
schaut einfach mal in der Infobox vorbei
da habe ich Holz kennen verlinkt und
übrigens mit dem Code mal war eine 15
bekommt ihr 15% auf eure Bestellung für
euch oder eure Liebsten und damit die
Holzkern ist jetzt wunderbar auf meiner
Haut auch zur Geltung kommen jetzt
weiter mit dem Kalender Beauty dann
machen wir einfach mal das erste Türchen
auf ne wir sind da mal so frech nein
hier ist es nicht es ist ein richtiges
Suchspiel ich habe das Gefühl ich bin
aber auch der einzige Mensch auf der
Welt der Body Shop nicht so auf dem
Schirm hat das ist wunderschön
doch nicht vor den Kindern tschuldigung
tolles Design also wirklich
in Tücher Nummer eins befindet sich
Handball im Sheabutter 100% recyceltes
Aluminium also das ist wirklich vegan
alles tipptopp hier ist sogar ein
Fairtrade Partner aus Ghana The Body
Shop macht wirklich alles damit man sich
gut fühlt das Produkt zu kaufen so
natürlich Nummer 1 Handcreme richtig
trockene Hände
oh es riecht gut nein doch
ah
nee doch es riecht gut wow das hat das
getan was eine Handcreme tun soll ne so
ganz vergessen euch zu sagen was
Adventskalender gekostet hat ich habe
den mittleren in der Preiskategorie
genommen also sie haben drei Stück und
meiner hat 100 €, also 99 € gekostet und
soll ein Wert von 164 € 40 haben also
die sind sehr explizit über den Wert
Originalgröße 7 €, also hier muss man
echt suchen wir haben für jedes Türchen
auch so eine Info warum das ganz tolle
Community in Mexiko
dafür habe ich mich extra nicht
geschminkt und sehe so aus wie ich
aussehe ganz wichtig der Duft Test in
Korea war bin ich ein Experte was
Gesichtsmasken angeht ein bisschen
alkoholisch das ist
ja aber der Duft Leute ich sage heute
durfte es wieder so ein bisschen auf
irgendwas ist komisch an dem Duft
es riecht nicht schlecht das ist weil
sie halt keine Duftstoffe oder sowas
verwenden ganz gut an da ist nicht so
viel Produkt drin das heißt man schmiert
das nicht alles voll und es läuft nicht
runter und so soll er Erfahrung bis
hierhin wie lange musst du jetzt drauf
bleiben 15 Minuten na das kriegen wir
hin kann ich Dir nicht einzeln kaufen
eine kostet 6 € eine Maske 6 € Nummer
drei Harmony denn sind Butter
waterproof Makeup die haben Make-Up
Entferner den werde ich jetzt nicht
benutzen weil also
wie auch ich bin passiert riecht aber
nach nichts gut ich habe jetzt auch die
Scheiße gesehen ich bin fasziniert die
haben in den letzten Jahren
wahrscheinlich ihre Sortiment erweitert
und ich habe es nicht mitbekommen ich
werde es in den Kommentar nicht gehärtet
dafür dass es jetzt nicht mitgekriegt
habe wahrscheinlich der beste Laden
aller Zeiten ist und oh mein Gott
deswegen haben sie auch so viele
wahrscheinlich empfohlen 6 € Nummer vier
schauergeldberry wer macht denn ein
Erdbeer Duschgel
das riecht voll gut das riecht richtig
lecker oh mein Gott ich liebe ich will
nach Erdbeere riechen acht Euro Nummer 5
ein Lippenpflegestift fühlt sich ein
bisschen billo an weil der Sticker auch
nicht so ganz fest dran ist so jetzt
jetzt ist nicht mehr belogen Flips
richtig gut Scheiße alles riecht gut aus
kann einfach jetzt in jeder Handtasche
die ich besitze Lippenpflegestift
reinmachen aber ist eigentlich ganz gut
7 €. meine Damen und Herren es ist
Nikolaus wir gehen in unseren
Adventskalender und wir freuen uns
extrem großes Paket
ist ein bisschen macht
die gleiche Serie wie Armand mirk
Lippenpflege ist das jetzt armed Melk
Seife clansing face and body Bar okay
Gesichtsseife das ist doch mal cool
ich hole das meiste aus jedem Kalender
raus wow
Gesichtsseife davon habe ich noch nie
gehört ja Gesichtsseife Kopf in die
verlosungsbox die werden jetzt hier
nicht das Gesicht waschen aber wenn es
so riecht wie der Lippenpflegestift dann
riecht auch toll 8 € irgendwie bis jetzt
die Preise angucken die Body Shop nimmt
dann ist es wirklich sieben sechs sechs
acht sieben acht also diese wenn Ihr
neues Produkt rausbringen machen sie
einmal so ein Pendel drüber und
entscheiden welchen Preis haben soll so
eins muss ich hervorheben das ist einmal
hier vorne ist es auch so aus diesem ja
so Naturmaterial und hier die Seite ist
auch das ist nicht also das sieht super
schön aus und hochwertig nice Nummer 7
Schauer cream share also aus der Reihe
riecht sehr gut ich möchte das Gerücht
dass Body Shop nicht gut riecht wieder
zurückziehen ich glaube ich habe da
falsche alte Informationen
Duschcreme 4 Euro es ist Zeit sich von
der Maske zu verabschieden 15 Minuten
sind rum na habe ich ein glänzenden
frischen gesunden Tag
Nummer 8 befindet sich das ganz
besonderes was für ein schöner Pinsel
das ist um sich ähm Masken aufzutragen
also solche Bilder
eine gute Qualität sehr sehr hochwertig
in diesem Pinsel gibt es nicht können
wir erstmal keinen Preis aufschreiben
okay halten Sie sich fest meine Damen
und Herren Türchen Nummer 9 kommt es ist
zwar sehr klein aber es wird ein
fantastisches Türchen sein Himalaya
Kohle das ist ganz wichtig die Kohle
muss aus dem Himalaya sein damit alle
Pickel weggehen ich würde mal sagen
unser sparerlebnis geht weiter letzte
Zimmer
aber frech verpacken sie in ein Türchen
den Pinsel sagt man hört sich mit diesem
Pinsel machen das nächste Türchen es
riecht in diesem Bereich gerade wirklich
wie in einem Spaß so dann nehmen wir uns
mal ein bisschen was runter
also muss man nur auf die Flächen rauf
wo ich so Unreinheiten habe ich frage
mich was dafür Stückchen drin sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das riecht wie Erdbeerkuchen ist riecht
einfach wie der Kuchen das kann er
Sachen können nicht so lecker riechen
ich kriege gerade so hunger auf
Erdbeerkuchen
übertrieben lecker
[Gelächter]
wie eine Droge gerade ach ich habe auch
noch nichts gefrühstückt ich habe
richtig Hunger strawberry Buddy Butter
die hat nur drei von fünf Sternen aber
kosten tut sie natürlich 6 € jetzt
möchte ich aber kurz mal herausfinden
warum sie nur drei von fünf Sternen hat
was ist denn euer Problem das kostet
beides mehr Smileys like dass die candle
finde ich nicht
mehr okay ich glaube es sind Bewertung
von Leuten die die strawberry Linie gut
fanden und jetzt nicht mehr tja bei Body
Shop spalten sich die Meinungen das kann
man schon sagen 13
ja doch auf jeden Fall nehme ich gerne
diesen ähm
ihr müsst euch mit sowas den Körper
waschen oder mit so einem
Massagehandschuh den man auch bei dm und
Rossmann und so kriege das Ding ist
nämlich man muss die Hautschuppen
abrubbeln damit die Haare die
Körperhaare und alles gut da irgendwie
durchwachsen kann ja wie heißt du denn
was bist du Real place our Plastik Bars
Lillys willst du Rami in natural plant
Base
siehst zur nature super gut äh excuse
music hier sehe ich aber noch den
Plastik
ne ähm
was kostet
übrigens wenn ihr das Video gerade seht
dann werde ich auf dem Oktoberfest sein
das erste Mal ich bin richtig aufgeregt
ich weiß gar nicht was ich erwartet und
freue mich einfach total drauf von dich
nach das ist die Shampoo obwohl das
macht schon benutzt man ja eigentlich
immer viel weniger an dich und Shampoo
aber nicht von der gleichen Linie ist
aber okay oder 5 € 15
doch geworden
[Musik]
endlich ein Produkt was stinkt ich
dachte schon ich bin verrückt 6 Euro 16
Vitamin C ach nie so richtig auf
Hautpflege globusing moistreiser oh das
ist nur eine Probe 50 ml da sind 20 also
ungefähr 10 Euro gib mir mal das hier
abwaschen und machen das drauf 20
Minuten später ist mein Gesicht jetzt
also das Gefühl war ein bisschen
unangenehm von dieser Maske machen wir
jetzt aber mal unser Serum drauf und sag
Globus die Konsistenz ist sehr matschig
oh mein Gesicht liebt es wenn ich mir
ständig neue Sachen darauf schmieren so
super Vitamin C ich weiß nicht wofür
Vitamin C überhaupt gut ist schreibt es
mir immer gerne in die Kommentare warum
man Vitamin C auf sein Gesicht klettert
ich glaube und keine neuen Mitesser zu
kriegen oh
wie süß speak up witch out and connect
the summer this time of you heart
kleine Challenge an euch schreibt
einfach jemanden den ihr lange nicht
geschrieben habt noch ein schauergel
also showergele sind jetzt sehr oft da
gewesen
ich weiß nicht wie die das hinkriegen
Pink Grapefruit und es riecht einfach
als ob ich an der Grapefruit rieche also
auch ohne irgendwas dazu einfach als ob
gerade eine Grapefruit vor mir wäre das
richtig lecker das weiß ich das kostet 6
€ Cheat Maske auch wieder mit Vitamin C
sollte ich nein
reicht mit Produkten in meinem Gesicht
ja klar und ich kenne mich aus ich weiß
dass diese sheet Masken 6 € kostet so
sicher bin ich mir auch nicht 6 €
in 19 lip Butter ich will die nicht
benutzen aber es riecht nach Kokosnuss
kann man eigentlich normale Butter auch
auf die Lippen schmieren und es ist dann
pflegen 8 €, bin auch nicht so ein Fan
von immer mit dem Finger so rein ich
weiß es ist auch ein schönes Gefühl aber
erstens habe ich zu lange Fingernägel um
da in diesem Böckchen da so rum zu
fummeln bin einfach ich bin Fan von
diesem so endlich die 20er
super
und das stinkt auch nicht es riecht nach
Hause es riecht wieder toll ja British
Rose magst du uns den klassischen
Rosenduft nicht auch nicht in Parfum und
so aber es riecht irgendwie so ein
Gummibärchen Hose 21
sorry aber das sieht Original aus wie
Guacamole die man sich dann am Körper
rumschmiert riecht aber nicht wie
Guacamole riecht einfach wie saubere
Seife 7 €, wenn ich an diese Vorwahl
Kalender denke und die Preise die die
Produkte dort haben ja es ist auch teuer
aber es ist halt nicht dieses oh mein
Gott 30 €. 22 noch eine Handcreme für
die erste Handcreme gekostet sieben das
wäre eine Verschwendung wenn ich das
jetzt aufmachen würde ich packs in die
verlosungsbox 23 okay ein Tag vor
Weihnachten also wenn man den durch
benutzt diesen Kalender dann riecht man
an Weihnachten wieder Body Shop noch
eine chipmast ich kann nicht glauben
dass die 6 € kosten soll das ist eine
einmal Verwendung aber gutes Produkt
noch mal kurz vor Weihnachten sich ein
bisschen frisch machen und jetzt sind
wir angekommen oh das Ding hat 25
Türchen 24 es ist Weihnachten Leute wir
stimmen zu unserem Adventskalender und
Kriegen unser Weihnachtsgeschenke
wieder Bodybutter 6 okay hier steht
jetzt happy Christmas also ich verm dass
dieser Kalender wieder eher aus der UK
kommt Großbritannien wo am 25 ja
eigentlich erst Weihnachten ist bei uns
ist es ja irgendwie Heiligabend dass das
eher so der richtige Weihnachtsabend ist
bei ganz ehrlich ersten Weihnachtstag
seid ihr da noch krass in
Weihnachtsstimmung also ja man ist in
Weihnachtsstimmung aber es ist nicht
mehr so aufregend so oh es ist
Weihnachten ich finde eher am 24 so ab
16 17 Uhr ist dann so diese Stimmung oh
es ist Weihnachten und hier ist zu
Weihnachten unser Weihnacht
kriegen wir denn tolles da da da da da
da da
Edelweiss klensing Konzentrat Edelweiss
oh da kam der Seifenblasen zwei 16 Euro
okay es ist auf jeden Fall das teuerste
Produkt was ist Edelweiss eine Pflanze
aus dem Alpen jetzt wissen wir es
wahrscheinlich schon vorher das war der
Kalender ne diesen Karton werde ich
definitiv für die Verlosungen benutzen
das ist ja ein wunderschöner
Adventskalender also eins kann man sagen
also außer dass ich sechs Mal Duschgel
bekommen Kalender trotzdem sehr
umfangreich also man kriegt man Cremes
Handcremes
duschlappen der Pinsel in einem Türchen
war ein bisschen weird das hätte man
einfach zusammen mit der Maske
reinmachen können meiner Meinung nach
jetzt gucken wir mal für unseren Preis
wieder kriegen ne
schon wieder eins vergessen ich flippe
ich habe 24 aufgeschrieben
sie haben nicht gelogen tipptopp jetzt
ist natürlich die Frage würde ich diesen
Kalender empfehlen nicht für mich denn
ich bin einfach kein Body Shop Fan also
dass ich da jetzt ausflippen würde
trotzdem war er sehr schön und es sind
alles Produkte die man super im Winter
benutzen kann also Body Butter Handcreme
Duschgel braucht man immer und Shampoo
Lippenpflege und so das ist eigentlich
das perfekte Equipment für einen langen
und harten Winter den wir in Berlin z.B
haben und ich finde auch ich habe mir so
mal Gedanken darüber gemacht braucht man
denn solche Produkte weil ich ganz oft
auch denke so oh ist das bescheuert und
hier und eine Ginseng reismaske aber
ganz ehrlich worum geht's denn im Leben
es geht doch im Leben auch manchmal
darum sich einfach nett zu machen und
ich finde gerade wenn man sich so über
Produkte freut die dann nach Erdbeeren
riechen und so das ist doch einfach auch
schön ist einfach nett man macht sehr
gerne wenn man sich so pflegt und sich
die Mühe dafür gibt seinen eigenen
Körper so gut zu behandeln dass man sich
das gönnt und diese Routine vielleicht
auch gönnen mit irgendwie eincremen und
am Wochenende eine Gesichtsmaske
benutzen und so es hat irgendwie was
Selbstliebe und so selbstwertschätzung
deswegen will ich gar nicht jetzt die
auch die nächsten Kalender irgendwie
darüber rumheulen warum jetzt irgendwas
sein muss oder warum irgendwie die
nächste Bodybutter und das und so ist
einfach sind nette Produkte ich ich bin
richtig ich fühle mich richtig ich habe
richtig Bock jetzt zu duschen und
strawberry Duschgel zu benutzen ohne
Scheiß also dieses Video ist wirklich
nicht von der Body Shop gesponsert ich
bin ein bisschen mehr Fan geworden und
das nächste Mal wenn ich im
Einkaufszentrum bin werde ich vielleicht
auch mal zur Body Shop reingehen und
vielleicht mal ein paar Sachen wieder
schnüffeln und denen eine zweite Chance
geben ich glaube das haben die verdient
besonders weil sie wirklich mit allen
Produkten ja auch immer diese Fairtrade
Communitys haben und glaube auch einfach
eine gute Message verbreiten wollen ich
habe sonst nichts zu erzählen danke
Holzkern für das Sponsoren wir sehen uns
dann das nächste Mal wieder
ihr solltet schon mal abschalten ja